invité du soir vous le savez tous les
soirs à 20h55 on vous raconte une
histoire on va revenir sur la triste
histoire de Patrice charlebagne un
professeur de 51 ans qui a été tué dans
la nuit de dimanche à lundi jusqu'à
maintenant tout laisser penser à un
cambriolage qui a mal tourné mais
aujourd'hui la compagne de ce dernier a
été placé en garde à vue pourquoi
quelles sont les nouvelles pistes Michel
Marie sera avec nous dans un instant et
on aura vous allez voir des audios
exclusives d'un collègue de Patrice
Charlemagne cette histoire est
complètement folle tout le monde en a
parlé aujourd'hui et on a les éléments
avant tout regardez ses élèves et un
collègue qui ont tenu à lui adresser
quelques mots regardez merci Olivier s
très gentille et très bien payant qui
voulait vraiment qu'on réussisse et sur
le coup c'est vrai que c'est un peu dur
de pleurer tout de suite ça dépend des
personnes il il était sympa avec tout le
monde même si un élève il faisait des
conneries il était sympa on en a parlé
on a fait une minute de silence pendant
la récrée bah on se pose la question
quand même qui est allé voir un prof en
pleine forêt et pourquoi surtout donc
surtout que c'est une personne qui avait
l' très très sympa moi je l'avais
rencontré à la Réunion par en prof et on
se demande on se pose les question pas
alors ils se sont trompés c'est pas le
bon prof bien entendu en régie ils ont
ils ont c'est pas le bon prof donc on va
voir le le témoignage dans un instant
les audio exclusifs d'un collègue de
Patrice là ça n'est pas leur bien sûr
c'est en Alsace voilà donc erreur de la
régie une fois de plus on a l'habitude
euh merci d'être avec nous Michel on
aura les audio exclusifs d'un collègue
de Patrice dans un instant euh 20h56 si
vous nous rejoignez cette histoire est
complètement folle
Michel c'est dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche la police reçoit donc dimanche
matin c'est pas c'est pas dimanche lundi
ouais c'est ça j'ai vu trois
dates dimanche à lundi en fait hein moi
j'ai plutôt le sentiment que c'est de
samedi à dimanche mais j'ai envie de
dire que ça n'a pas une
ance primordiale alle donc dans la nuit
samedi à dimanche ou dimanche à lundi à
4h du matin la police reçoit un appel
d'une femme en détresse qui dit qu'elle
a été victime d'un cambriolage et
qu'elle est dans une sur la commune de
Rosendal qui est la la banlieu de
d'unkererque donc la police arrive très
rapidement sur place c'est qu au fleurs
c'est une petite maison isolée qui est
le long du du
canal et elle est isolée avec des des
terrains maréchés tout autour cette
femme est en panique elle a un bébé une
petite fille de 20 mois dans les bras 4h
du
matin et elle explique qu'elle a été
réveillée par des cambrioleurs elle en
site de elle évoque deux individus
parler dans un instant de cette histoire
elle évoque deux individus qui seraient
qui auraient pénétré chez elle hein
voilà qui l'ont réveillé et elle indique
au policier que son mari se trouve à
l'intérieur et que il y a eu une bagarre
et qu'elle a réussi à prendre sa fille à
sortir pour prévenir la police donc
évidemment les policiers rentrent à
l'intérieur de cette maison et décou
couvre au premier étage dans une chambre
un homme inanimé dans une marre de sang
qui a été lardé de coups de couteau je
crois qu'il a pris 12 coups de couteau
et essentiellement des endroits vitaux
c'estàdire le cou le le thorax et
l'abdomen alors euh on va écouter les
parce que vous allez nous raconontter
l'histoire en même temps déjà qui était
Patrice
Charlemagne Patrice Charlemagne est un
était un homme de 51 ans il était
professeur à
l'Université du littoral de la côte
d'Opal il était également agrégé
d'allemand
euh c'était un homme assez complet il
aimait la musique il était auteur
compositeur il jouait du saxophone et il
était donc en en couple avec Justine qui
était plus jeune que lui qui est âgé de
37 ans et il venait d'avoir une petite
fille de de 20 mois d'accord euh ils
sont ens vous savez depuis combien de
temps ils sont ensemble parce que c'est
important pour eu alors j'ai pas le j'ai
pas l'information c'est vous allez voir
comment l'histoire est est incroyable he
alors euh on a eu un collègue de Patrice
charlemag avant qu'on continue
l'histoire donc à l'Université du
Littoral Côte d'Opal il nous explique
d'abord comment le personnel de
l'université les étudiants ont appris ce
drame
écoutez c'est notre président
d'université qui m'a appelé lundi matin
à 7h pour me communiquer cette très
mauvaise nouvelle qui m'avait demandé de
venir à l'université pour prendre les
décisions nécessaires et les étudiants
qui sont en contact avec lui ont été
accueillis par euh les collègues de l'UT
où il avait cours lundi entre-temps on a
mis en place une cellule d'écoute
psychologique à laquelle les étudiants
et les personnels peuvent
s'adresser alors on aura d'autres audios
voilà donc c'est vrai que quand ils ont
appris la nouvelle c'est incroyable donc
c'est un cambriolage à dunkererque qui a
mal tourné dans la nuit c'est a priori
ce sont des choses qui arrivent première
la première piste he c'est ça oui la
première piste c'est l'hypothèse du
cambriolage d'ailleurs la la compagne
Justine indique au policier elle évoque
deux cambrioleurs on retrouve le le
corps de son compagnon l'ardé de coup de
couteau en faisant le tour de la maison
les policiers vont
retrouver des effets qui proviennent de
la maison c'est un ordinateur une deux
paires de gants sanglanté une lampe
torche qui clairement ont été utilisé
alors est-ce que ça a été mis là à
dessin ou bien est-ce que c'est
dans leur fuite les cambrigoleurs
auraient lâché cet ordinateur en tout
cas dans les premières heures dans les
premiers instants de l'enquête on est
sur un cambriolage on est sur un
cambriolage donc deux personnes et elle
dit
quoi la femme de de de Patrick charlemag
l'épouse elle dit elle dit quoi elle dit
qu'ils sont rentrés comment comment
comment elle raconte l'histoire parrait
qu'on a tout ça parce que vous allez
voir comme l'histoire a tourné
aujourd'hui et que c'est fous qui le
rebondissement est incroyable j'aimerais
savoir si elle a donné des détails si
elle a expliqué ce qui s'était passé
elle donne peu de détails dans la mesure
où elle dit qu'elle dormait qu'elle a
été réveillée par deux individus qui
étaient déjà à l'intérieur de de la
maison d'accord
euh effectivement les choses ont très
vite enfin très vite en trois jours
c'est la police judiciaire qui a donc
été saisie de de cette affaire mais elle
elle raconte donc ils sont réveillés
dans la nuit Gill et il y a une BAGAR
donc c'est quoi par c'est ça que
j'aimerais savoir VO il ils ne dorment
pas dans la même chambre donc elle dit
qu'elle a aperçu deux personnes maiselle
elle dit qu'elle dort avec l'enfant et
que le mari dort à côté dans la suite
parentale donc elle dit j'ai juste vu
j'ai juste eu le temps de sortir et mon
mari lui est resté là quand elle passe
le coup de fil à la police c'est ça
voilà et donc c'est vrai en plus des
gants et cetera ah ils ont retrouvé à
l'extérieur aussi deux couteaux donc au
début ils se sont dit il y a une vague
une petite trace d'ffraction donc ils se
sont dit les policiers et bien les
cambrioleurs ont été surpris avant qu'on
arrive ils sont partis en laissant des
affaires voilà alors
ça c'était la première piste exploité
qu'est-ce qui se passe ensuite alors ce
qui se passe dans le détail c'est
compliqué mais mercredi donc ce matin la
police judiciaire a interpellé je dis
bien interpellé ils ont pas convoqué ils
ont interpellé donc c'est pas c'est pas
anodin Justine donc la compagne de de
Patrice et ils l'ont placé directement
en garde à vue
euh le parquet a communiqué en disant
que il voulait le but de cette garde à
vue était de
vérifier les informations qui avaient
été données par Justine par rapport les
comparer avec les éléments matériels les
indices qu'ils auraient retrouvé sur
place alors ça peut être de tout ordre
peut être de la vidéosurveillance ça
peut être de la téléphonie ça peut être
de l'ADN ça peut être tout un tas de de
de petits de petits indices où
clairement les policiers se posent la
question euh se disent le cambregalage
on y croit pas trop
et c'est quand même assez rare que la
femme de la victime soit placée en garde
à vue de cette façonl aussi rapidement
parce que pour placer quelqu'un en garde
la vue il faut quand même quelques
quelques billes comme on dit des indices
graves et ou
concordants et ça on a parce que ça a
commencé ce matin on n pas encore le le
détail de ça on va on va parler de
l'hypothèse dans un instant qui est
privilégié maintenant la piste voilà
prendre bien sûr conditionnel qui qui
est évoqué juste
avant elle était connue à
dunkererc oui oui Justine était connue à
dunkererc donc elle avait 37 ans elle
était également professeur elle était
maître de conférence elle enseignait la
littérature euh c'était un elle était
également conseillère municipale à la
mairie de d'unkererque euh voilà c'estit
quelqu'un de très connu dans
euh ils ont eu un enfant il y a 20 mois
c'est ça c'est ça et est-ce qu'elle
avait déjà eu des problèmes avec la
police à ma connaissance non d'accord
euh est-ce qu'il y avait des problèmes
dans le couple parce que maintenant on
on va vous donner dans un instant
l'hypothèse voilà qui est privilégié
mais est-ce qu'il y avait des problèmes
dans le couple il y a un témoin qui
évoque que la victime Patrice
Charlemagne se plaignait de de son
histoire de sa de sa vie amoureuse de sa
de sa vie de couple mais on n pas là
encore le détail mais clairement il y
avait un problème au sein de ce couple g
ça va faire parti des éléments que les
enquêteurs veulent vérifier c'està-dire
que non seulement la confronté
au fait à ce qu'ils ont trouvé aux
indices mais également voir si le couple
allait bien comment ça se passait c'est
pour ça que ils ont voulu tout de suite
avoir son récit de sa vie de couple et
ils vont s'attacher à faire la lumière
sur effectivement le l'état du couple
donc un cambriolage qui tourne mal la
victime aurait reçu beaucoup beaucoup de
coups de couteau qui 12 coups de couteau
à la carotide dans la poitrine et à
l'abdomen donc la police se dit ça
pourrait être autre chose qu'un simple
camb bririolage qui a mal tourné puisque
c'est vrai que là on a l'impression
qu'on a voulu voilà éliminer Patrice
hein un cambrioleur surpris par le
propriétaire pour se dégager de la
mauvaise situation va peut-être mettre
un ou deux coups de couteau pour se pour
se sortir d'un mauvais pas mais 12 ça me
paraît énorme et 12 on dit souvent que
c'est d'ordre passionnel c'est vraiment
la l'envie de de de supprimer de
détruire le la personne qu'on a en face
de soi et puis à la présence de ces deux
couteaux un peu plus loin il y avait
peut-être plusieurs personnes dans cette
dans cette affaire alors évidemment
justice jotam la compagne du défunt
reste présumé innocente pour le moment
mais il y a une hypothèse qui est en
train d'émerger Michel et gillin Michel
oui l'hypothèse c'est effectivement à
partir du moment o on place la compagne
en garde à vue comme je dit tout à
l'heure justement c'est ce qu'a dit
Charlotte la procureur de la République
après examen des témoignages déclaration
constatation technique et scientifique
le parquet de dunkererc a décidé ce jour
du placement au garde à vue de l'épouse
de la victime l'objet de cette mesure
est de confronter comme vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure sa version des faits aux
éléments recueillis dans l'enquête
puisque là il y a une autre piste qui
est privilégiée maintenant donc par par
la à mon avis dans ce qu'elle a raconté
dans les premiers instants de l'enquête
est ce que les policiers ont trouvé en
faisant leur leurs constatation avec la
police technique et scientifique il y a
un problème il y a quelque chose qui
colle pas donc peut-être
que n'y est pour rien peut-être que la
garde à vue
euh percera cette ce ce mystère mais en
tout cas il y a un problème entre ce
qu'elle a raconté et ce que les
policiers ont constaté alors j'ai la
piste maintenant qui est privilégiée ce
serait donc euh bien sûr à prend alors
bien sûr elle est elle est présumé
innocente puis on va voir le contenu de
la garde à bu mais la piste potentielle
c'est que ce serait possiblement un
drame passionnel et et ou un crime
commis par une ou deux personnes
c'est-àdire que maintenant comme il y a
deux couteaux les enquêteurs veulent
savoir comme il y a une trace des
frrations est-ce que c'est quelque chose
qui a été pensé à l'avance avec une ou
deux personnes est-ce que la compagne et
la maman de l'enfant étaent protagoniste
de ça voilà les Tau pendant la garde à
vue encore une fois vous avez raison
cyil présempption d'innocence totale
bien sûr mais lo va se resserrer autour
d'elle pour la confronter à ses
déclarations est-ce que elle est pour
quelque chose dans ce crime voilà donc
est-ce qu'elle l'aurait commis
exactement seule avec la complicité de
qu la femme donc l'épouse de patri la
compagne de Patrice est-ce que on a
est-ce que parce qu'il y a eu aussi des
choses chez lui tout et n'importe quoi
soign on aa dit voilà que c'est elle
voilà qu'il aurait deux personnes quand
même qui aurai qui seraient rentré dans
la maison que voilà c'était pas des
cambrioleurs mais qui sont ces deux
personnes voilà s'il y a deux personnes
parce que de Coutau qui sont ces deux
personnes est-ce que il y a un
commanditaire de ce qui s'est passé
voilà quel est son rôle voilà est-ce
qu'il a est-ce qu'elle a joué un rôle ou
pas et si elle a joué un rôle lequel
voilà voilà principale ou secondaire
fortuie ou entre guillemets prémédité
voilà toute la question de la garde à
vue alors elle a été placée ce matin en
garde à vue aux alentours de 11h elle y
est toujours hein Michel Marie c'est 24
en 24 hein donc c'est 24 he renouvelable
par sur décision du GLD et exactement si
elle a été placée en garde à vue euh
comme vous avez dit elle a été
interpellée donc c'est si les policiers
ont besoin d'avoir une précision surtout
quand il s'agit de la compagne de la
victime que le crime est assez récent on
imagine que on prend des gants avec
cette personne et que la placé en gardef
l'interpeller c'est pas forcément
prendre des gants donc ils auraient pu
la convoquer si c'était anodin je pense
qu'il l'aurait convoqué en lui disant
est-ce que vous pouvez passer nous voir
dans l'après-midi au au service on a
trois questions à vous poser là ils se
sont déplacés ils l'ont interpellé ils
l'ont placé en garde à vue ça laisse pas
entrevoir forcément une suite heureuse
pour cette personne alors des proches de
Patrice charleman vous avez tous entendu
cette affaire aujourd'hui aura indiqué
que ce dernier se confiait beaucoup ces
derniers temps sur ces problèmes de
couple et que il s confié de de plus en
plus de personnes oui oui il a un
faisceau de d'orientation peut-être de
déclaration qui établirait des problèmes
dans le couple et d'ailleurs Cyril quand
vous avez cité la déclaration du
procureur vous avez dit examen des
témoignages des déclarations
constatations techniques et
scientifiques témoignages et
déclarations ça veut peut-être dire que
déjà la police judiciaire a obtenu des
témoignages sur peut-être un malaise
dans le couple des choses la procureure
a brassé large elle cite plein de
faisceaux potentiels qui les ont
orientés vers la compagne donc cette
histoire est folle puisque c'est une
femme qui appelle dans la lui qui dit
qu'il y a deux cambrioleurs qui sont
rentrés dans la maison et qu'elle a
réussi c'est ça qu' faut qu'elle dit
elle elle a réussi à sortir de chez elle
et son mari est en train de de de d'en
découdre avec avec les les les les
cambrioleurs donc elle elle aurait dit
donc qu'elle serait rentré dans la
maison ensite et qu'elle aurait donc
retrouvé son mari avec des 12 coups de
couteau c'est ça ça c'est la police qui
dit ça elle elle attendait la police
dehors tout le début ça va c'est ça elle
est en train de dormir elle est
réveillée par le bruit mais elle dit
quoi les com il éétait masqué il Ctait
comment elle arrive à les décrire elle
donne pas de détails elle elle voit deux
furtivement deux deux individus de
silhouettes dans c'est la nuit he tout
le monde dort il est 4h du matin
récupère sa fille elle comprend que ça
c'est les choses se passent mal elle va
pas à l'affrontement et on peut la
comprendre si tentz que son histoire
soit vraie et ensuite elle prend sa
fille elle sort et là elle appelle la
police et elle attend la police devant
chez elle euh g est-ce que on a vu donc
on cette hypothèse là il y a l'autre
hypothèse aussi qui surgit depuis
quelques quelques heures c'est que ce
serait voilà c deux personnes qui
auraient prémédité le le le geste voilà
absolumentitéel la maison est isolée ils
étaient pas là depuis longtemps donc on
se dit un cambriolage voilà on retrouve
un butin très faible avec un ordinateur
à l'extérieur ex c'est ça donc le Buttin
c'est quoi parce que le cambriolage
est-ce que ça tient debout un ordinateur
donc on se dit alors peut-être qu'ils
ont été obligés de fuir précipitamment
puisqu'elle s'est réveillé mais ça
paraît très étonnant pour un Buttin si
faible donc est-ce que ce sont pas des
éléments qui ont été placés pour faire
croire à un cambriolage alors que tout a
été prémédité et organisé en amont
est-ce que ça a été organisé par des des
rivaux du professeur est-ce que ça a été
organisé par sa compagne voilà toute la
question là où le choc est aussi
terrible c'est que on l'a dit lui c'est
un intellectuel et elle aussi elle est
connue regardez avec Jacques avant elle
a elle a écrit de multiples romans pour
la jeunesseelle plusieurs papiers dans
la presse en plus pour son son
parcoursur docteur en en
français elle a un parcs maître de
conférence donc voilà sont deux
intellectuels donc le le drame est
soudain et c'est pour ça que adunkerer
qui est dans la France entière c'est le
choc absolu alors on a eu eu donc ce
collègue de Patrick Charlemagne il nous
dit voilà que c'est un professeur très
apprécié de ses élèves comme du
personnel pour parce que ça fait partie
aussi d'enquête pour voir s'il avait
voilà des pas voilà l'Université du
Littoral et c'est vrai qu'il était
apprécié de tout le monde
écoutez c'était un professeur très
intégré très enthousiaste très apprécié
par par ses étudiants il avait un
enthousiasme pour les langues pour
apprendre les langues vivantes pour
transmettre cette passion qui était
vraiment
apprécié de tous et nous sommes tous
vraiment très affectés par ce qui s'est
passa donc voilà donc c'est vrai que
c'est c'est c'est ce qui ressort voilà
l'istoire et lui-même le connaissait
très bien il partageait des intérêts des
activités communes c'est ce qui nous a
dit j'avais pas mal de contact avec lui
parce que nous sommes dans des
disciplines assez proches donc lui il
enseignit ma langue maternelle donc ça
crée certains bien sûr et bon je le
connaissais surtout comme un collègue
très sympathique qui participait
toujours aux activités que nous
organisons à l'atelier culture alors
voilà donc bon c'est ce qui disent donc
on va attendre là demain on va savoir
des 11h si la garde à vue est est
prolongée et si elle est prolongée
Michel c'est que bah ça sent déjà pas
très bon mais là s'il est prolongé ça ça
va vraiment sentir très mauvais très
bien merci Michel merci à vous tous tout
de suite c'est magéon sur c'est
moncheville sur mer